رغم ان المعارك في السودان مركزها الخرطوم
الا ان اقليم دارفور وعنصر مؤثر في النزاع
الوضع في الاقليم يبدو اكثر تعقيدا من
العاصمه حساسيات عرقيه وقبليه انتشارا
للحركات المسلحه المنبثقه عن حرب استمرت
16 عاما بين عامي 2003
2019 رسميا تحاول الحركات المسلحه في
دارفور البقاء على الحياد سعيا لتجنب
اشتعال نيران الماضي في الاقليم ونحن ضد
فلان ولا ضد علان
لا نجيف ننشر للفلان ولا ننصر للعلان لكن
نحن دائما ما محايدين نحن ما محيدين ليه
لانه هذه التراب السودان هذا الوطن
السودان هذا الشعب السودان هذه الامراه
السودانيه نحن نحميها
لكن رغما تصريحاتي حاكم دارفور بعض
الحركات شارك الى جانب الجيش شاركت الى
جانب الجيش ضد الدعم السريع تحت لواء
القوات الامنيه في المشتركه التي تتالف من
الجيش والشرطه والحركات المسلحه الواقعه
على اتفاق سلام جوبا للتعامل مع الانفلات
الامني والنزاعات القبليه وحمايه المدنيين
في الاقليم امر اكده وزير الدفاع السوداني
ياسين ابراهيم ياسين دعم قد يفسر عدم سقوط
ولايه شمال دارفور ومركزها الفاشر تحت
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع ورغم انها مسقط
راس حمدي
قواتي الدعم السريع للسيطره على كامل
ولايات دارفور الخمسه سيدفع الحركات
المسلحه للتحرك واغلبها ستكون في صف الجيش
[موسيقى]
لكن دعونا نلقي نظره على مناطق الاشتباكات
في اقليم دارفور يتفوق الجيش نسبيا في
ولايات شمال دارفور وشرق دارفور دارفور
بينما تسيطر قوات الدعم السريعه على جنوب
دارفور في مدينه نيالا مركز ولايه جنوب
دارفور تسيطر قوات الدعم السريع على الجزء
الشرقي من المدينه بما في ذلك مطار نياله
اما قوات الجيش فتتمركز في النصف الغربي
الذي يقع به مقر الحكومه في شمال دارفور
اندلعت اشتباكات في مدن كبكايه
وطويله والفاشر الفاشر تحديدا شهدت نشره
خمسه جمعات مسلحه مواقع على اتفاق جوبا
لمئات المقاتلين على مركبات الرباعيه
الدفع لتامين المدنيين ومقر المؤسسات
الحكوميه والمنظمات الدوليه اما الولايه
المشتعله حاليا فهي غرب دارفور الحدوديه
مع تشاد والتي كانت المع قل الرئيسي
للتمرد في عام 2003 تعرف بتضاريسها
المعقده وخاصه جبل مره مدينه الجنينه هي
نقطه النزاع المشتعله حاليا في غرب دارفور
ولا يسيطر عليها اي من الطرفين حتى الان
وبسبب هذا الوضع المضطرب فهناك مخاوف من
سيناريو الحرب الاهليه في دارفور مره اخرى
عدد كبير من السكان يرفعون الاسلحه من اجل
حمايه اسرهم وممتلكاتهم مع غياب اعداد
كبيره من منسوبي الشرطه لدرجه ان وزير
الدفاع السوداني الفريق ياسين ابراهيم
بنفسه دعى كل القادرين على حمل السلاح
القيام بذلك والدفاع عن اسره
م الحقيقه هو ان دارفور لم تخلو يوما من
السلاح اكثر من 84 حركه مسلحه مئات الالاف
من قطع السلاح منتشره منذ حرب 2003 الحرب
التي تسببت في انتشار الثمان ملايين قطعه
السلاح في ايدي المدنيين وفقا لاحصائيات
رسميه حينها ورغم محاولات السيطره على
الامر لم تتمكن الدوله من جمع الا 300 الف
قطعه في الفتره ما بين 2016 الى 2020
السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات